this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised good afternoon everybody in a
very good afternoon on this Sunday
coming to you live from the Mara
Triangle in Kenya my name is Steve
joined by big James on camera and
there's a very blustery and cool
afternoon although it is 26 degrees
Celsius 79 degrees Fahrenheit there is a
big storm a-brewing from behind us but
we've managed to find two big male lions
cuddled together yet don't quite know
who they are just yet I'm hoping some of
you out there will be able to give us
some identification if you know who
these two pretty boys are don't forget
you can interact with us live on hashtag
Safari live or throw in your comments or
questions on the YouTube chat stream we
came a little bit further sort of south
to areas are a little less sort of
inundated to bother rainfall the ground
is much harder here we did make our way
past sort of a hyena den area and the
ground is still saturated with the
previous few days of rain so thankfully
we've managed to find these two
beautiful boys who were sleeping under a
very nice fig tree and they have now
moved out and they've been sniffing and
smelling the wind that's coming from
this side and maybe we can still see
them they've been having a little look
at these two ground horn balls over here
that have walked with about maybe 60 70
yards within reach of the lions but the
Lions have had a look and they've
thought about it but they haven't moved
haven't moved at all and I've tried to
sneak up on ground hornbills before and
although the name ground hornbill is
their name they do fly quite well and if
you get within 30 40 yards of them they
will take off and fly away and that'll
be the end of it and the many times I've
actually seen them just flying off big
black bodies with white tips on the wing
enormous wingspan
but the largest cooperative breeding
birds that we know of but back to the
gorgeous boys that everyone's commenting
on how gorgeous they are the guy on the
right has got a number of sort of wounds
on his left-hand side of his face which
he's not showing us at the moment but
aren't they gorgeous
nice blue blonde mane on the right see
there's not any darkness in the Mane's
here now a lot of people always talk
about dark mane lions and sometimes you
get blonde males and it's all really a
genetic thing that's inherited from dad
but anyway good news down in South
Africa Tristan has been on the search
and has found a cat oh really
let's go and see which one we have
indeed and as you can see we've got
appearing lies of the old Juke thing I
know he was having a little nap on top
of a termite mound he hasn't moved too
far from where he was lift last night
and is now just taking it very easy kind
of gazing around these women parlors
that were around us now that he was kind
of watching and that's he's just been
feeling kind of chilled I think
eventually he will go hunting this
afternoon it's just gonna take a little
bit of time that's for sure but it is
very very good way kind of to start our
day well at least I think so anyway my
name is Justin as Steve mentioned on
camera I put sins are this afternoon
very warm welcome to South Africa this
size have kids somewhat since this
morning and it is a much prettier
afternoon than it was this morning and
so we've ditched the rooms and
everything is much drier which is very
nice and obviously you ting Ghana is
posing as well as well as we could ever
ask for that's for sure he is kind of
really sort of found a nice termite
mound to be able to sit and just watch
what's going on very very very cool to
kind of see that he's hanging around I
was hoping that we'd find him today I
was a bit worried yesterday because when
we left him his general direction was
north towards before the cut lines I
didn't think that we had find him today
but at the end of the day we got lucky
and like I say he came out and he's
actually hit it more south this
afternoon than anything else and then
eventually found this beautiful termite
man to sit and
you look at ever so regal on top there
like that he's kind of yeah obviously
aged a little bit but hanky look still
looks in fine form considering how old
he actually is I think he's looking
really really good
I'm haven't seen too much of that lump
today is school there a little bit but
nothing too bad he'll be fine I mean
last night by the time he started
walking properly he wasn't limping at
all he was family around like he
normally does very exciting way to start
though isn't it
well I think so anyway right well we're
going to sit with Tigana for the whole
of the afternoon he certainly won't be
going anyway and so while we sit with
him and see if he's going to make a move
let's send you across a two tree Sharla
so she can see tell you what she's
planning for the afternoon yes well
that's really so lucky that we've got
ting gana again today it's always nice
to have a leopard on Drive but I have
something single would much like to eat
I think and those are two little baby
kudos how cute is that
I think it's spectacular my name is
Trish ala and I've got Craig on camera
with me and we're going to be looking
for all sorts of interesting things in
the bush today starting of course wood
kudu and you know we've started with a
little bit as well so that's pretty
awesome I think oh and there's a larger
cooter up on the side this possibly mum
over to my right just excuse my head
there
there were also a few Impala that were
rutting behind him of displaying a
little bit but as soon as he knew I
wanted to put him on camera he bounded
off as they do even this he wasn't this
female kudu doesn't feel like showing us
her face
there she goes eating away it's actually
quite a nice temperature out here today
it's about 28 degrees Celsius 82 degrees
Fahrenheit so it's very nice and mild at
least for me so there's lots of these
browsers out and they're all having a
bit of a snack the leaves on trees are
still a little bit juicier than the
grass is at the moment so you'll find
that mixed feed is like the impalas
we'll be eating a lot more of those
leaves and then trying to get the nice
juicy bits at the bottom of the grasses
out to much like this little guy anyway
I'm going to move on and we're going to
have a look in the West as usual for any
sign of another leopard in the meantime
let me send you up to David in the
Maasai Mara
hello hello and jumbo jumbo everyone and
yes sir shall I you need do keep moving
and hopefully you are going to get maybe
lumber well the weather here is
fantastic wonderful weather and where we
are we got some glorious landscape left
red from where we are and welcome to
this part of the mass tomorrow Steve one
is on the other side my name is David
and on camera is Archie Archie thank you
very much
we just want to show you the kind of
landscape record and the weather that
you have here that's just breathless you
know we haven't seen any animals yet but
that is all our equipment and this
should tell you I am already in the
Soviet republic great temperatures Steve
must have told you earlier sure the
clouds as yet we do not see any cloud
that should worry me and Archie in terms
of rain so far so good
I'm only getting a few bites in there
from the supplies and I'm sure your no
supplies sometimes will cause what you
call sleeping sickness how to kill in
one of them but if you get bitten by a
fly it is so so painful it's just like a
syringe you know being thrown in your
flesh see this close there do not worry
me and many times you hear me and
steve-o button Lauren Tokyo tomorrow
triangle is because of that couple in
their loose clouds for me look fine
Lesley duckin much later
well I'm sure Trish and Steve already
told you to keep talking to us and
gauges as much as you can Janet you say
this is good yes so what I need to get
for you Janet is to get you the sausages
themselves because I am already in that
particular territory and that is my very
main plan this afternoon Janet so stay
tuned do not go anywhere because chances
are we might get them today so she don't
show me as much darker clouds don't put
any worries in me
and I want to move on but in time let's
go back to the other side of the Mara
are we evolved with his lions good job
and good luck Gigi I hope you do manage
to find the sausages and good news for
massa the storm seems to be blowing in
the other direction but we scanned with
our binoculars and you see the tree line
at the back there wait for it three two
one
there's two lioness there and I saw
already two little ones so we're gonna
go but close enough let's go and see who
they are we are in the area when I have
spent time with the salt lick pride so
I've got an assumption that it might be
them but who these two big males are I'm
really asking your guys help out there
can you tell me who these male lions are
that'd be wonderful but it's because see
if we can have a look a little closer at
some cuteness would you like that
Kel six the kitchen boys are I've seen
them before they've got a little bit
dark in the main and they are they
normally are much closer to the
escarpment closer towards kitra itself
and we are thirty kilometres 15 odd
miles maybe from there so I'm not going
to guess it's them I do know those boys
I have to spend time with them before I
do not know these two so I doubted them
if anything aren't there we go there's a
little yeah oh is that a youngster it's
hard to say from this distance here's a
couple youngsters one on the left and
one on the right so these are probably
dad one of this and underline is on the
left is at least three youngsters
well let's go and have a look shall we
go find out exactly who these
individuals are and then we can get a
little bit closer how does that start
I'm happy if you're happy let's just get
into low range don't worry boys
we'll be right back for you here if you
do decide to get up and move but
definitely not
definitely not the the kitchen boys
that's for sure and not the old Anya
pikes because I know those two males so
we're just gonna go straight over here
and who is this gonna be I'm thinking
Salt Lick Brad I haven't seen them in
some time but then I haven't been around
thereby it's a good bumpy Oh Vic
Welbeck you're saying something that I
was almost getting to the assumption of
as well BEC saying it could be the two
young sausage tree pride males that were
around with Kapoor Lee that I was having
that thought for a moment but I really
don't know them well enough I didn't
spend enough time with them but
definitely we could be in the right area
because they would have displaced
themselves I've seen Kapoor Lee in this
area before just up there against that
main road he was mating with a female
but possibly one of these females in
fact by the size of these Cubs okay it's
getting very bumpy yeah there's one two
three I've got three Cubs already so
it's very rocky yeah four cups three
Linus hold on everybody a little bit
bumpy oopsie
basalt rocks we're gonna stop right
there then we just roll back off of the
off of the rock here we go these little
cuties here yeah I thought I had a
fourth one there's two there's one in
the grass to the left of us he tries to
hide hello youngsters about four months
old these Cubs four maybe five months by
the size and I saw that male lion mating
with one of the I think it is one of the
Salt Lick pride females it is difficult
I must tell you everybody James the two
youngsters are playing just on the left
there's a little bit of a little bit of
lion play happening so it is difficult
to identify lions and really is it takes
a lot of identification a lot of photos
a lot of ID kits to be able to really
get your head around them sometimes
local knowledge is is very very
important and obviously you viewers at
home have got your ability to know to
get your screenshots and to get all the
information out for us and send them
through unfortunately when I am in our
vehicle doesn't receive any Wi-Fi so I'm
not able to even check my ID kits so I'm
hoping some of you out there
while we're looking at the Cubs first of
all and because they're so cute
and we'll focus on the females a little
bit once they put their heads up and
show us a little bit more action in the
Cubs are doing hopefully give an ID of
them but makes sort of sense that
they're the salt dick pride but I really
am NOT going to stake my life on it
right now
so far three adults and three Cubs I
thought I saw a fourth one but that
might have been a rock
I do blend in so wonderfully well with
their surroundings don't they yeah we
are very blessed look at this office
look at this view for the day lions and
the Mara over the backdrop look at that
isn't that just a marvelous scene last
time I was here that scene was littered
with thousands hundreds of thousands of
all the best and on our way in yep we
did pass the three very grumpy looking
Buffalo so maybe these lines including
the two big males behind us will decide
you can catch one of them for some food
who knows when it's windy like this you
often get lions getting up and moving
anyway don't worry folks we will be
staying or at yet where the action is
the meantime good news in South Africa
James is on Drive and he would like to
say good afternoon
but we do not have any action um eh good
afternoon and welcome to the sunset
Safari here on a Sunday t2 28th of April
19 no not 1919 it is 2019 my name is
James Henry on camera today Sebastian de
jambe
the greatest French Japanese air force
pilot in history and this of course his
little friend Marvin so all we called
her I think so anyway there will be
flying
Marvin around the place hopefully
helping us find Columbo or Tandy that is
why we've come into this area so we're
sitting here at all we're not sitting me
driving along Central Road and that is
because we had tracks of a female
leopard here today this morning doing
that rather Pleasant rainfall for those
of us who weren't actually out in it
then had some rain out here and and he
had the tracks and I think that you'll
find that Sebastian will not in fact
agree that the rain was pleasant is that
correct
not really yeah no fair enough
Sebastian insisted that we delay the
morning meeting by 15 minutes so that he
could go and shower himself and put some
warm clothes on and many thanks to all
of you who said you missed me so much I
missed you too
Radhi the first thing we're going to do
is stop next to this vast vulture which
doesn't seem to be on the ground at the
kill site this is very interesting
oh it's a leopard faced vulture oh
that's beautiful look at that oh well
done that's the lappet-faced vulture
everybody very large vulture and
Dominator of carcasses and in the other
bird that was up there was a tawny Eagle
II now this area was where there was a
dead Steinbach yesterday the Tristan
found and we investigated a little bit
later on
and we didn't actually manage to find
anything other than the carcass but the
fact that these birds were not on the
ground tells me that maybe just maybe
we're going to be lucky and there is
actually a predator there there we have
got a bat earlier juvenile on the right
and left two teenagers having a Sunday
afternoon tryst remember those days
Sebastian when you were a teenager
having a Sunday afternoon turist
hopefully not over rotting carcass and
hopefully you didn't behave like that
one on the left there in front of your
beloved good
they're sort of gentle autumnal weather
today bustling dry leaves gentle breeze
pleasant smells all right we're going to
go and see if there's something next to
this little caucus well we do that let
us go back to Tristan Dix and the
laziest leopard in all the world I can
agree with James is a very pleasant
smell in the air after the rain although
I think it's a little bit too little too
late I don't think we're gonna see too
much green grass kind of coming of it
I'm pretty sure most of the grass has
really lost its lignin and is starting
to fall over and with the cooler
temperatures in short today's rain that
we've gotten largely you're not going to
do too much and it wasn't enough to
really fill up dams as soon as we get a
little bit of hot where that will dry up
most of what we had but at least it's
something it's better than no rain
that's for sure
as you can see Tigana who's hadn't been
quite a way he's been watching and
looking around quite a bit but he's just
sort of popped his head down now to have
a bit of a nap and I think he's gonna do
much like what he did yesterday
afternoon which is probably sleep for
quite a while and then as soon as it
starts to get dark then he'll start to
get moving and start to go looking for
any semblance of food
it was interesting watching him last
night he would walk a little bit stop
walk a bit stop and eventually he found
a series of holes much like he did a few
weekends ago and just sat up there and
then kind of watched towards the holes
and he obviously spent most of the day
or night there last night because where
he was found this afternoon was very
very close to where that was so um his
obviously his strategy at the moment is
just to do that is to find certain holes
in the ground that he tension he thinks
this may be odd fox or warthogs and then
just sits in wait in the hope that
something comes out that he can in
surprise it and grab its doesn't seem to
have been too successful of late because
we haven't found him on any kills
particularly things like Bigard fox or
warthogs but you never know they must be
some method to his madness and it's
probably easier been going around and
trying to chase things
like compilers and steiker and Steinbach
and the like so that's just kind of
tactic at the moment and I'm interested
to see what he kind of gets up to this
evening in which way he's going to go
you know he spent the better part of
almost two days and are really hanging
around this the damn area we're not he
actually not too far from the dam and so
it's very possible that he might decide
to kind of get up and start moving and
hitting away from this area but we'll
see how it goes
and we'll see what happens and where he
heads off to you you can see he's a bit
of a celebrity today he's being
photographed by many people and say he's
a bit wide eyed when shutters go off but
I'm pretty sure we're gonna
unfortunately have to make space for a
whole bunch of people and rather do it
now early before the TV show then later
so we'll probably go meandering apart
for a bit and then come back and while
we do that let's enjoy prostitute Steve
and see how he's getting on with his
lines
well good luck there just to know
hopefully that Jukka gets up and does
something this evening and we're not
going anywhere
we're in a prime position now I still
only managed to identify three cups but
in a fourth Linus suddenly showed her
head see if you can spot her there see
if you can spot to everybody imagine you
walking through the long grass look at
that that would be quite frightening
wouldn't it a majority of them are at
the stage is fooled covered in grass
like that where it wasn't burnt and that
is the favorite hunting ground of the
Lions up here in the Mara
it's horny cats using the stealth of the
long grass camouflage for now they're
just using it for a nice little pillow
Franchesca since Albania haven't heard
any information about Scarface or the
Musketeers James do you have any info on
then no haven't haven't heard anything
it's been pretty slow going of late and
with with cats due to the fact that most
areas are quite inaccessible because the
rainfall so we're in an area that seems
to be relatively dry today but there's
been no report of him who knows he might
have gone further south there's a number
of whatsapp groups and giving
information on the sightings and what's
being seen and it's been a very very
quiet there we go see mom on the right
is becoming a jungle gym and see if this
one's going to join in the charades
better look at these lionesses faces now
none of them have stood up yet I mean
the sausage tree pride could even come
this far if there have been moving if
those two males are the old sausage tree
pride males then there wouldn't be any
risk rule you'd think to the Cubs that I
haven't managed to get any
identification identification features
of yet to tell me if any one of these is
indeed one of those so for now we have
got a pride of lions playing in the long
grass cuteness overload
hello Lindsey yes it does well where we
are right up on this sort of rocky area
it's very very rocky and doesn't have
the same soil type that you'll find down
in the valleys so the soil is very
shallow here you probably noticed on my
way image was very bumpy but this entire
valley this entire area left in the
right of us was burnt last year so those
enormous fires put through here and that
would have eliminated a lot of the old
grass that would have grown up on these
hills and there where you can see the
lionesses walking the sort of a rocky
alcove that would have protected that
grass from the fire that raged through
here and that's how the trees also
protect some of these little rocky areas
because the fire is often sort of kept
away from very rocky areas as to kind of
like a retreat for certain trees you'll
see them often arching very fire prone
environments that fire doesn't get up
but this entire valley and we see on a
left here James can show you the entire
valley there was burnt last year and we
had so many of all the best in this area
and it was a really good area to come in
a sort of experience and to drive
through unfortunately if we go a little
bit more left from where we are now a
little bit more down on the valley and
we don't get these signals so we're
quite happy where we are right up on top
of this sort of Ridgeline that we do
have signal and we have lionesses with
Cubs and I think the two males are still
sleeping behind us this is the best time
of day temperatures have cooled quite
substantially because of the storm that
is all around little pockets of rain
falling in many many different areas and
you can see by the wind how much it's
would cool everything down as well when
initially we found those two males I
couldn't see these lioness although I
did scan all around they're probably
hidden in flat in the grass or maybe
they're a little bit more covered in
there by the bushes as the male lions
are both sleeping in the shade and then
as the wind picks up they went and lay
in the Sun
because obviously the wind kept them a
little bit cooler since then I put my
jacket on so definitely is much cooler
afternoon and 26 degrees Celsius
implies okay everybody well if any of
you have any Rd on the lines we've
managed to show you so far please send
them through on Twitter hashtag Safari
lava in the meantime let's go back down
to Sharla in Juma for an update
well I'm also looking for some sort of
cat I'm in the West and I'm scouring
through and haven't had much luck to get
but I am looking for tracks and looking
on the sides as well the problem is
because if they heavy rain this morning
and you can see how different it is if
you watch the sunrise Safari how
different the way there is right now
it's bright and sunny and what's that
stun is the water has wet the ground and
then dried the ground so it's actually
quite hard so unless an animal is
walking with quite some force or you're
lucky in a certain part let's have a
look at these guys certain type of soil
then you're lucky enough to see those
tracks so that's what I am looking for
at the moment and I'm checking out the
West it's been a while since we've seen
shedule oooh ohoooh Komori so I would
really really like to find them I'm sure
these warthogs would prefer that I
didn't find her Kimora hooker Marie
anywhere close to them
he utterly allows warthog
maybe I should actually follow them
before I know it Herkimer he might come
out
who they've seen something
and possibly just better food books
think they have seen something actually
one looked off into the distance
we move a little bit forward so we can
have a better look they didn't look like
they were looking very seriously in that
direction but you got to check these
things out cuz you never know they were
looking at a group of Impala Kimberly
you think warthogs are so cute I think
they're so cute too
they're little piglets up so adorable so
it looks like they were just watching
these Impala that were there so nothing
too exciting but obviously got their
attention so this is a bachelor group of
males they were probably sparring
amongst themselves and having a bit of a
practice rut waiting their turn got the
attention of these warthogs that were
eating nearby the impalas are you happy
that now during your season you're
getting a lot more publicity or being
through getting famous
got with a one guy in the middle who's
chewing away I love watching them when
they are chewing their cud is you see
them swallow it and then they throw up
another little boy oh how was that
little kick I'm glad to see that these
guys are taking care of themselves you
can see the one is cleaning so often
during the rutting season you'll find
males that are ooh that looks like a
face-off oh I love how the ruminating
one at the back doesn't care at all this
looks like when you're trying to wrestle
with your mates and you say okay okay
hold me hold me here
no this hurt told me yeah being very
very careful but still trying to have a
go at fighting with each other that one
in the bank doesn't care at all he's
just trying to eat his his cut
so this little group obviously males who
have not yet found themselves territory
instead they've banded together oh how
was that yon now that was actually a
really nice display of how the herbivore
jaw can't really open in the same way
ours and ours can as and up and down in
the same way a carnivores Joe can't move
from side to side and you'll find here
when he yawned you can see it kind of
had to do a big circle because it can't
just simply go up and down like our jaws
can with a hinge instead it's got to be
on a horizontal plane from side to side
I've never actually seen them you on
like that is the first time I saw a
really nice example of that jaw movement
and back to feeding and cleaning
gremlins are getting me these days and I
hate it but I will defeat them in the
mean time that may send you over to
James who is not having the issues I am
for the more experienced of you you're
probably looking at me saying Oh surely
he's not going to explain the magic
worry to us yet again and I am NOT I am
in fact going to use this magic worry to
punish myself why you might ask
well I misidentified that vulture of and
it was of course a white back to vulture
thank you James Richard and so now it
falls upon me to punish myself severely
it was a white-headed vulture correct
yes what did I say
I'm glad and I'll show you the
difference between the two three in fact
I've missed two mistakes hello Janice
you say I'm still a guide no I'm not I'm
a naturalist please bear my strap
Kirsten right now what we had of course
was the white headed vulture over there
it looks at first glance very similar to
a lappet-faced but really an inexcusable
mistake from somebody who's been around
here for as long as I have and those are
those two and then the white backs of
course will you all know that one I
didn't actually think it was a white
bear because I just took the white you
know and then it was a slip of the
tongue there it is ah quite exhausted
after that self-flagellation
obviously if I'd had a spike to whip of
some sort I'd have used that
James should you say that was a bit
unnecessary well that's very kind of you
to say that it was unnecessary I don't
feel it was I feel thoroughly
embarrassed and I think I should I think
I should feel embarrassed and I'm hoping
that the severe pain I feel all over my
body now is going to help me to remind
me myself not to make that mistake again
good right so we've come down here
because we thought we heard some Impala
alarm calling we checked out the caucus
it's exactly the same place as Awards
yesterday to know why the birds aren't
feeding on it they definitely have been
feeding on it but now they've lifted
we heard some alarm calling but it
seemed so far away so we're we've
checked chela pan which is north of us
we're now going towards twin and damage
haven't found any tracks but we are
certainly doing our best but affected
with this because it doesn't actually
hurt that much it looks much smaller
than probable
I believe the villains are now punishing
me so we'll go back across the Steve in
the master map well James if you punish
yourself with a branch I don't I wish
I'd seen that I'd like to go back and
watch a replay I'm sure all of you are
going to be uploading into the
Twitterverse some wonderful images of
James beating myself maybe we need to do
a little jeff however you call it a gif
a little repetitive little images please
everybody send one of them through
needed a little chuckle before I go to
bed this evening kirsty agrees yes
Kirsty Greece everybody please see who
can make the best one and send them
through well now what's very interesting
and it's something we don't see with
hyenas and we do see with Lions all the
times the communal suckling this lioness
who's been there in the same place the
whole time I noticed she had some suckle
marks about the two cubs at least two of
em one was just playing with suckling on
the first lioness you saw them playing
with and now they've gone over to this
one and she's allowed them to suckle as
well it's one of the the things that
lionesses will do communal suckling cuz
they're not generally related well for
the most part lionesses are always
related and generally also breed at a
very similar time you've seen the baby
boom that's happened here it's happened
in the past lioness was often
synchronised breeding so as to maximize
the number of Cubs that will actually
make it to adulthood and they don't mind
a suckling each other's youngsters it's
my sister or my daughter's Cubs
essentially there's relations there and
upset and selfish gene of asmar genetics
going forward so something we see in
lions all the time but we do not see it
in AI enas and well it's a little bit
interesting the dynamic there isn't it
and well one of those is a boy but I
could tell that he was getting quite
quite feisty with us
- that's lying with her back to us
snazzy you want to know that while lions
are compassionate - while other cats are
not
well ants are the only social cat that I
can think of the only one I believe and
they when they feed on a carcass there's
a lot of aggression that takes place a
lot of fighting it happens at this early
stage as well if there's a third cub
trying to suckle is going to be
competition for that milk so from an
early age they learn to be competitive
and they learn to be quite sort of
aggressive with each other that's how
you need to survive as a lion but then
after all the sort of the bloodshed or
all of that the anger is God or
dissipates and there's a lot of love and
a lot of compassion that is is
distributed between them and grooming
and all that sort of thing because they
do need to be cohesive imagine if you
fought everyone every day you're not
going to be a very good hunting unit are
you if yes you punched me this morning
you clawed the back of my head fine I'll
kind of lick you you see it very very
often with young males that are in a
pride that inner beating up mum quiet
sort of aggressively at the kit of the
feeding zone and then later on that
evening he comes back to mum and he kind
of store sort of like licks her and goes
I'm sorry and didn't mean to be so so
dominant early happening sorry I
scratched you on the face and they need
to be sort of social it is how they've
evolved and that's how they've probably
turned the corner from what was the
leopard and they've moved into these
much larger predators who need to be a
unit to take down much larger prey a
lioness can be quite successful on her
own excuse me but she is far successful
in the pride and they're far more
successful at rearing Cubs in a pride
than they are on their own
here we go she looks like the oldest in
the group little cab sneaking up there
let's see what its gonna do is always
naughty when in cabs are moving around
whoo I'm gonna scratch its head first
bit of a lick there was lots of grooming
going on as well
each of the Cubs had went to whatever
lioness was there got a proper body lick
all the parts were properly groomed
seems like it's licking its lips as if
it's possibly been suckling that might
have been suckling on the lioness we've
lost a visual of lying in the long grass
there so it's possibly at least three of
these lionesses are suckling currently
so the Cubs all look very much the same
size if they are from the same litter or
not they were probably conceived at a
very similar age
hey Jessica that's a great question I've
never physically known a lioness to say
or for them to go and look at each other
and kind of pull straws and go who's got
more milk they that's all about the
lionesses need to eat if she's got food
she's hungry I mean she's gonna go hunt
and is it's the way it works and if
those Cubs haven't suckled yet well
they'll have to wait until she gets back
but the whole cycle of it works is in
that each lioness has the potential to
stay behind at any given stage you don't
always see them all going off and
sometimes they do or go off but then
often you'll see them coming back like
this to a communal sort of area maybe
these covers have been stashed in that
little rocky area for the evening the
lionesses aren't maybe hunting and don't
think they were successful if they were
I wasn't a very big meal at their head
but it means that any one of the
lionesses can stay back if she has cabs
at the time or at least is nearing
having Cubs because they start producing
milk before obviously they can't before
they give birth so each of the lionesses
is able to look after the Cubs there we
go you can clearly see the spots on them
now that one looks slightly smaller than
the other two but they are all very very
similar in age the one in the middle
being the young boy so far that I've
identified I'll see if we can identify
the other two everybody David is about
seven or so kilometers south east west
of us he's on the search of the sausage
tree pride
okay
all right
okay let's take you to crucial as if I
not want to be a parent well yeah
you look at some of these leaves ah
gremlins are all about her see I'm
really hoping they stop with me and that
I've had enough of me but what I would
really like to show you of course I'm
still looking for the leopards and I was
actually hoping maybe a lion or two or
ten but unfortunately they still seem to
be in the North in before sook and not
down here in Juma nevertheless I will
still be there right at the top I'm
almost completely in the north at the at
the border so hopefully I'll check in
there if I see any tracks coming in then
I'll know that they probably might be on
Juma which would be excellent for us but
while I Drive through I'd like to show
you some leaves that are changing color
this one is a nice example scenic you'd
like to know what I think is the cutest
antelope in the bush
my favorite antelope in the bush kudu I
loved kudu I think they're beautiful and
handsome and the colors are spectacular
just like the colors of these trees now
the tops of all of these trees and
starting to kind of wilt and you'll see
that they're all changing color now it
doesn't really happen in the same way as
it does in the northern hemisphere when
you get those whole deciduous forests
that change color when autumn comes
around but here you can see that they're
kind of dried up and I've got that
yellowy orange color to them and almost
all the trees around at the moment have
these colors and you'll notice that the
one that you're looking at now which is
a complete him gets nice and yellowy
before it gets brown and falls off
whereas the round-leaf teak which is
just at the bottom of that Cambria tomb
there we go you can see that there's
still some green leaves and then it goes
yellow and then red towards the bottom
of your screen there you can see a few
of the redder leaves and then it gets
black of course
as it falls so you can see that the
seasons are most definitely changing and
you'll see it a lot with the
completeness as the color changes it's a
really pretty warm color and as I'll see
also some marula trees that have been
changing a pretty color as well if I
find one of them I'll show it to you now
it's really interesting how that color
works so you know that chloro plot a
chlorophyll fold with chloroplasts
create this green that we see in plants
and what happens is when this resources
gets kissed it gets colder drier less
nutrients around it stops nutrients
going to certain leaves because now it's
saving all its its energy and by doing
that chlorophyll no longer gets
maintained in those leaves and so what
happens is the other pigments that are
in the leaves get a chance now to be
seen so that's what happens when we see
the reds and yellows of trees that are
changing with the seasons is actually
the green pigments been stripped away
and now we can see the other pigments in
the leaves which i think is quite
interesting we only think of it as oh
it's dry so it must have just dried
which I suppose is not incorrect but
it's not as if that is just a result
from of dryness it's a result first of
those pigments being taken away
I am being into the sunset at the moment
hello please get me there we go
something like a bit of a I type sticky
thing all I know is it stung me or it
but me or whatever it did but it's itchy
now I'm going to eat you nothing's gonna
be coming now you'll hopefully but in
the meantime
well we've unfortunately had to leave 10
Ghana because it's just just chaos then
my blood pressure was starting to rise
and so I thought better of staying there
before I got irritated and upset with
somebody and so we're now waiting for
all of them to cycle through so that we
can get back to tango and I just now I
mean as we kind of left we bumped into a
Terrapin that must be very lost at this
stage because we are now kind of in the
middle of the Malati nowhere near any
water to funnest and this poor guy is
kind of walking around now or he's
calling me again qdubs
okay copy that awesome whereabouts easy
now
okay coffee thank you that's over he's
just telling me what's happening with
Cheng ani is keeping me updated because
he's worried that they might lose him
and then we won't be able to find him
now
why I've stopped you and I'm looking
with my own binoculars is to our
right-hand side at the moment
I'll stop quickly just sorry since I
know it's a terrible angle that I've
stopped yet but in underneath that tree
there so over that area is a den site
that unused for Columba quite a lot so I
just stopped just in the off chance that
maybe she's milling about in the end
just quickly add a little look at the
moment it's one of those kind of games
where it's worth just stopping at every
kind of potential the insight that we
know Tandy like to use and just check I
mean you never know maybe we get lucky
and she's sitting inside but no one home
today so definitely not giving birth
there and this is the game that's going
to have to be played is just kind of
kicking and hoping and eventually
they'll maybe find her but I wouldn't be
surprised she's gone on to torture it
and I wouldn't be surprised she executes
a berth on tortured to be honest with
you but we'll see how it goes let's just
keep sort of hoping that she stays our
side the other dense eyes she uses on my
left-hand side actually there's that
fallen over tree there so some of you
will probably recognize that from
Columba that's where she used to kind of
keep telling but quite a bit so one was
the side and the other one was that side
and they used to play on that log quite
a bit so she's not anywhere to be seen
in this area know her he's talking to me
yeah a fair mobs um basically remember
attendees all kaya's so just trying to
find out creating ganas heading
I'm just listening now
all right so Aubrey's telling me that
he's heading straight towards us at the
moment all right copy that orbs are just
on the southern side of that little dip
well that little drainage lines I'll try
and head roughly toward central see if I
can pick up your audio all right so
we're gonna try and see if we can find
or be always very kind you're gonna make
a space for us so that we can carry on
following Singhania
and so while I try and find ting Ghana
and all be in this mess and it seems you
back across to Steve
good luck Tristan time no doubt the juma
guards will allow you inept so you can
keep up with the troupe of drummer who
always materializes just in time for TV
doesn't here's a superstar Oh lightning
in the horizon the mountains and the
background there that is the the wall
allure mountain range you can see the
lightning is striking under the
escarpment
so I wanted to show you in my book yeah
just so you get a bit of a reference of
where we are it's gonna put on the
dashboard yet and get an idea we're over
here
this obviously is a map of the mara
triangle here is where we are and the
Tanzania border is this line along the
bottom quite easy and so David and the
sausage tree pride is kind of in this
area that's where they kind of been
hanging out but it's not that far it's
about seven kilometers but to catch your
airstrip I've got to go up all the way
up here and then if I turn the page just
to keep going keep going and then it
starts here again and keep going and
here is where Kitchel airstrip is all
the way over here so the kitchen males
this is where I've seen them spending
time if they've come further south than
that I'm not sure but we're in a very
very different area from that altogether
so I'm just going to go back to the
first page you get an idea of where we
are
so my first initial guess of about 15
kilometers were about 20 kilometers from
from Kichler which is not an enormous
amount of distance for lions to travel
I doubt those males would have come down
this further south the female seemed to
be a bit more fluid in their movements
but the lion dynamics our chair is also
quite crazy last summer so the Lions
we're nowhere near any of the
territories anyone was saying there were
and I'm back again and well this is the
first Lions I've managed to find apart
from a pair of lionesses that were
walking up I rode towards our camp last
night and right in front or next to FC
alanis it's night whilst it was brushing
his teeth just outside his tent about
seven eight meters from his tent a
lioness killed a water bucket
Sammy Jane you wanna know how lionesses
don't injure their teeth when they are
fighting when they are killing well how
does anyone not injure their teeth I'm
you trying to bite things that are too
hot lions will use their teeth for
ripping flesh and with the side of their
teeth for breaking the bones that they
possibly can break but invariably the
lionesses teeth will break after a
period of time and that's something you
often notice in leopards and lions with
age and you'll start seeing the canines
are worn down
they might even break teeth and lose
them altogether they don't have the
benefits of a dentist and like we do
back home once the teeth are gone pretty
much that's it so that's something that
quite often is seen in sort of an old
lioness or more should I say in a
leopard a leopard that gets very old of
teeth wear down it gets very very weak
it struggles to catch food may become
quite dangerous and that is the reports
down south africa if anyone has been
caught or attacked by a leopard it's
generally a a sick injured individual
that has probably broken or lost some
teeth and has struggled to hunt so when
they're in the pride like this they're
still pretty good at hunting and they
aren't able to break those really big
bones that the hyenas then not capable
of with probably the strongest teeth in
the animal kingdom crocodiles are able
to replace their teeth the teeth that
snapchat all the time once one of those
teeth break will fall out they've got
another cone of a tooth busy growing
right underneath of the first one which
is quite incredible so obviously due to
the fact that the
teeth quite brutally used during their
life but lions the canines are very
important for killing or delivering the
final blow and the side carnassial sheer
for carving and tearing flesh anyway
true Charla Donna South Africa her
search continues but she's managed to
find herself a beautiful elephant I
finally found what I've been looking for
it's not exactly the leopard but I've
been looking for these elephants too and
I'm so glad to see them and we have a
little one amongst them hello little one
I think this might be a mum off to the
left slightly bigger female and is also
a youngish male bringing up the rear
cute little family
oh I've missed them so much oh this
one's got a kinky tail
this is quite odd look at all of their
tails actually no to that tail and now
note this females tail and even the
youngsters tail seems to have a bit of a
kink I wonder if it's something I've
just never noticed or it's some sort of
Jean
now that tiny one that you are looking
at you can see there's little tusks
slightly poking too so that tells me
it's about 3 to 4 years old maybe
actually a little long younger those
those little tasks are quite small I
would say about 3 and it's quite a small
group now you'll see this often in a
herd they'll separate from each other to
feed and other things and they'll often
do this even though their home ranges
are massive they'll move across move
across them not always as a big group
but sometimes in these smaller family
groups
sweet let's see they've been moving onto
trees much like all of the animals at
the moment the herbivores that are
around seemed to be moving about and
eating from the trees little more often
as days go by yellow one they didn't
even come to say hello these ones I love
when elephants come close to the vehicle
and don't you say hello to you relaxed
Lisi is one K times the one that you are
looking at the little one and oh there
we go oh no mommy moved right across
your little one I wanted to show them
how it was using his trunk no she's
going to show us instead
highly dexterous pulling off all those
tasty bits from that that looks like a
russet bush real oh that they eating at
the moment
it's quite remarkable that change you'll
see as the seasons change in the way
that the animal's diet will change the
habits will change I mean it was just a
few weeks ago and we were still seeing
elephants mostly eating grass
and looking forward to seeing how their
dung changes I love looking through it
and seeing the differences
I suspect there may be others around but
not very very close I haven't seen too
many elephant tracks around either so I
was actually surprised when I stumbled
upon these three
they're lovely I hope I'll be able to
catch up with the rest with the rest of
the head if there are more around I
really hope they are anyway let me keep
on going I've done my Border Patrol here
a little bit in the meantime let me send
you over to Tristan while I keep looking
rut so we saw with dinger while we
rejoined Tigana but he's heading to
where we were looking just now and
apparently some of you say that there
was a leopard on a frame that we had
just now of that fallen over log and so
he's kind of staring in that direction I
had I honestly did not see a leopard and
neither did sensor which she's got the
sharpest eyes of all of us but maybe it
was just hidden me and I just missed it
completely which is going to be
surprising but the waiting on is
behaving it's possible that they could
be another leopard here given that there
was the way he's been sniffing and he's
just stopped and stayed and he's hitting
exactly exactly the way we were framed
up on that log just now when I was
showing you that tandy has another day
it will has had another den before and
so let's see how we go and see whether
or not we get lucky here maybe there is
another leopard if it is another leopard
no.11 wanders doesn't it now James him I
think my ear is about to bleed with the
amount of talking I've had to deal with
today go hey James not James's fault
James's first time I've heard him on the
radio so we don't blame James with this
game but everybody else has been
shouting and carrying on and there's
been no decorum today and there needs to
be some lessons taught I think so I'm
going to miss James Henry on everybody
at some point to teach them all about
having some manners on the radio
all right so the log that I framed just
now that's you guys are saying there was
another leopard he's right here in front
of us it's just on this other side here
and so let's see if King Ghana hits me
and another lipid jumps out
well then we'll know for sure or won't
we I'm hesitant to head to coast and
I'll tell you why
because I don't want if it is Tandy I
don't want to be that poster
no ting Ghana's right here next to me
I'm just gonna quickly jump down on top
mmm smells like popcorn the bass smell
in your in the bush is the smell I'm
just gonna do jump down hold on sins
because the log is just on our left hand
side yeah oh how is that for a picture
hello boy
you're right above us isn't that cool
that's awesome
he's standing I would say maybe five
meters from where I am at the moment and
he is no he's heading straight to that
log since let's just go forward a little
bit
she is hitting across I don't see a
lipids but maybe I'm wrong
he's walked right past it and he hasn't
interacted with anyone I don't see
another leopard coming Art's
so Lu says she can't see anything in the
shots but that's the log apparently
there was another lipid at that log I
honestly did not see anything but but
it's possible I suppose
I just wanna lose ting Ghana I'm gonna
just go up and around back to where we
were when we had that first shot and try
and see if we can
get some sort of view of what's going on
here
is there any screenshots coast of of the
said leopard and it's all winning sort
of
let's alright so I believe cursed is
saying she's looking on the replay she
can't see anything so I don't know maybe
so but Andy's just been found but not
yet so she's been found not far from
where we are James I think is heading in
that direction
he's tanana's way off if there was
another leopard sure there's no ways he
would have gone as far yeah there's
definitely a little bit there that I can
see he's gotten way too far I mean like
I say if there was another leopard
there's no ways that other leopard
wouldn't have noticed him or him notice
the other leopard the ability to smell
and pick up scent is very very very good
in these animals and so there's no ways
I'm afraid if there was one that ting
Ghana would have missed it but anyway
we've caught up with Dingaan and eyes
mobile straight down milliwatts he which
is not good for us cuz he's going to
probably cross off this property rather
quickly if he keeps up the pace that
he's walking at the moment
is another school they're driving down
the mall whitey with a leopard it's like
that iconic thing when you come to do
more for you ever in the sort of sabi
sands you're always your thought is a
leopard walking down a drainage line or
a riverbed so it's always so nice when
you get into a place like this and
you're able to kind of follow a lipid
through now it'll be a bit careful of
our ant in it through here
ah look at that we managed to avoid the
antenna completely good we're gonna keep
up with Singhania we're gonna keep going
hopefully James will get to Tandy in the
meantime and while we do all of that so
that sends you across to David in the
Mara with some crap Ching gonna well
done don't go anywhere because I'm sure
you go to the right posture review
Tristan I've spotted some homeless from
a distance then they have taken off and
why I want to show they can catch up
with them because the very rare hundreds
currently in Africa and they're getting
quite vulnerable and every time I try to
go close to them they are moving you
hover they are just driving
I see we can capture them from here
before they take off again
there what she called the southern
ground hornbill how beautiful to see
them about four of them and they live in
big groups you really see one it will be
two three four sometimes up to ten it's
beautiful I'm sure I don't remember the
last time custody who is directing the
show so they seldom ground hornbills see
how the blending they come in value or
rather the contrast between their them
and the green grass all right at the
interval yeah Steve had to before
while Steve had to I got four and there
could be picking anything smells and any
other insect of beaters should just grab
it and solid straightaway and if you
look at the big scale it's like they
don't close very well they look like
they're open build stocks but they got
very path mix I'm sure Steve might have
mentioned currently these birds are
quite vulnerable if you look at the
early listing by the IUCN
and the main concern is loss of habitat
and then they'd about three years or so
for them to you know bring up a full
cheeks to be independent and fully grown
three is such a long time that to me
could be a female the males have such a
bigger and bright water than they yes
the mayor our guests think you are G and
you see that sucker below or the base of
the beak it looks quite big white
balloon and I'll call that kind of a a
male display child of the universe
should let you know what exactly they do
it well like most birds offices will
start maybe classifying or the each
other the universe by looking at the big
if you look at the big the biggest quite
huge it's like a chisel and most birds
will eat both you know they're both
either cannibals and Hardy was at the
same time or we could we could call them
omnibus but child of the universe would
say the ground hallways are more canvas
than anything else they will eat any be
toasted lunch and I also tell you they
also eat tortoises can you believe that
and what they do when they grab a
turquoise they don't even which killer
just a bit slow that beak is so powerful
and they used it like a chisel and they
open the shells of the child in the turn
trees and get and get the flesh from it
so basically each other the universe
would say is but are more carnivores
than there'd be happy versa
I don't I'll get the little cartoon of
get a fruit here or some seeds there
once a while but mainly they are
cannibals tortoises snails
beetles grasshoppers cicadas if they'll
get them locusts if they'll get them and
now with the range that you have the
Mara now we've got so many of these
types of insects out trying also to feed
I mean this instance being happy was and
try to feed on the grass or blades of
glass
or SIDS then these hundreds will take
the advantage we also see their coverage
breeders
so should you see four or five six of
them there could be mainly a couple a
male and a female and then either
cousins will be helping to raise the
chicks huge BOTS they do fight as much
as they look very big and they will
always nest what you catch their little
nest on very huge solid trees on holes
of solid trees I'm sure they are having
a party they're not sure exactly who
they're feeding on when you look at the
base of that red watch off for the
females they have a bit of bluish
pinkish and good question and you asked
to the ethnics Ian 100% the ethnics
sometimes end of last year I saw one
that had held a snake for a very very
long time and the only thing and what
what what it wasn't able to do and like
snake he was in I think it's very
difficult for them to kill it because it
held that snake for a whole twenty
minutes before it is swallowed it it
tried to kill it
it couldn't and unlike other birds that
we just you know swallow out sea snake
so wholly I'm talking about
let me see are the Secretary's but
Harris cut snakes snake he goes or
martially goes for example cut snakes
and saw them still live I think the
challenge for these birds just to eat
them or some of them on they're still
alive they need to kill him very good
and I hear more good news of spotted
cuts in South Africa James who do you
got
hello everybody there is the spots that
can't end well let's see if James
Richard can identify win if you can
identify this cat from there I know it
is cuz I've seen her face it'll be a bit
I bet they're a few of you who could
actually identify this cat from just
what you're seeing there now we are
surrounded by Impala here on both sides
of this cat and I believe that in Ghana
is heading straight towards this area so
I'm not gonna move just because you can
see she does seem to be well yes was
stalking I'm just gonna get back a bit
there we go yes I think you should have
a sit lift no no she's there left a bit
yeah she's in that gap up up up yeah
I've seen enough and all of you same
array yes Tandy indeed it is Tandy well
done
sorry everybody quite stick in here and
I must tell you the game drive radio has
been a level of well professional that
would make
I'm trying to think of something a
deeply unprofessional
a riot basically it's like a riot
okay the cat is just over there walking
now straight towards team Ghana you can
hear the impalas are very much the wiser
of her presence now fully aware of her
I'm just gonna let the other vehicles
stop moving around first and then we'll
carry on quite possibly Colombo also in
this area
I've heard all briefs I've got a lumber
there now as well let's go
till to the lift kangana's now running
this way just to the left here another
lipid wind running just in there
there there there
okay let's carry on with tandy Columba
is to the right
something for us so we've lost him any
little integrated sorry about that
everybody our aerial has detached itself
a piece broke off right okay never mind
we're okay Tandy's gone off there
Columba is there we will get the camera
onto the cat as soon as Sebastian is
reattached the aerial there he has she's
on the tree there you see snip beautiful
I let kitty now she's Columba panties
just to the right of where she's looking
and ting Ghana's heading this way so I'm
gonna move now
let's get into a better position
all right Trust is coming this way let's
go back to him now with ch in Ghana we
are indeed so we're not very far at all
ting Ana's here on my right-hand side
and just straight through the bush I can
see where James and the rest of the guys
are they're a little bit kind of south
of waiting arnaz facing at the moment
but given that Columbus here Tandy's
here he might bump into one of them and
he is kind of followed his nose and run
all the way to this area and is kind of
in the mix as well so we've got three
leopards in the space of a very very
short distance which is absolutely
amazing it's been a long time since
we've had a trifecta of leopards
together and it's super exciting when we
get to see them all and I want to see
what the reaction is of tani and Tigana
to Columba and whether or not she is
going to be all right right now I
believe James is with tani so let's
quickly send you across to them look
we've got both of them here they're
having a bit of a fight Tandy is
salivating and actually being miss of
the aggressor fascinating so you saw
that little hit there
as little Columba heading towards us now
and she was the one being aggressive not
in ganas running towards us and that's
because of the sound that no doubt they
were making the ganas coming right here
I'm gonna wait where we are because we
put Columba now just three meters from
us let's quickly go to an unscheduled
fast as possible hello everybody welcome
to the western fringes of the great
kruger national park my name is James
and record Sebastian on camera and we
have got three leopards in the offing
here to them in front of us this is
little Columba she's aged 18 months and
just behind her her mother Tandy and
they're in a slightly sort of aggressive
state because they are separating from
each other to lumbers becoming
independent but to throw more into the
mix the father of this young cat is on
her way in here
the Duke of Jummah ting gana so this
afront exciting going on here it is very
very special indeed the sound you can
hear in the background well it's the
sound of a parlour alarm calling now
Tandy is basically starting to try and
make tramber move away and become
independent and we think she may well be
pregnant now there's other sounds you
can hear a human beings obviously
talking their guests in the sighting
here comes the mother now I'm just gonna
get out the way mum is growling you can
hear again
that hissing is the daughter the
growling is the mother that's the
daughter you looking at there number
now we've got the father coming from
the right hand side which I haven't seen
yet but he live being attracted by the
sound of this fight and what's
interesting is that we think tongue the
mother flicking her tail like that he's
in fact pregnant again possibly with
another of ting ganas offspring well
mayor good question from you there is it
okay for us to be so close you know it
is because we know these cats well but
also they have approached us
now she's chuffing so that's called
chuffing I see that that's a kind of
it's a very friendly greeting it's a non
aggressive greeting and I think she's
looking at her father I don't think
they're dead there's the father to the
right hand side there we go
Destin gonna he's coming now he's
smelling where tündi was marking her
territory now we're gonna get all three
of them in one picture that is fantastic
that is not something you see every day
isn't this magical so we've got there
the big old dude in Ghana aged 13 odd
and his daughter's approaching him that
is just beyond magical there's been
physical contact and watch she's
chuffing all the time at him chuff-chuff
there you can see the little movement in
her face
just saying to her dad hi dad I don't
mean any harm
it's lovely to see you now she's
chuffing at her mother who's moving
slightly away towards the right-hand
side it's also darling
it's gonna move forward slightly
everywhere it's just the most magical
sighting
we'll stop there there we've got her
daughter approaching father again tummy
is just off to the right hand side she's
sort of slowly moving away now but
what's amazing about this is that you
don't read it in the textbooks you don't
read about especially daughters having
contact with their fathers like this
especially when there is old as years
I'm sure it does happen but we don't see
it often this is so special and
especially that there was a physical
contact Holly you say this is amazing
yes it absolutely is quite stunning
now daughters running after mum I'm
gonna move again once ting Garner's
pulling Venus yeah
not tight little telomers running off
your mother whoopsie daisies we're
parked on a ski stump just try and get
out of here it's amazing now we've got
another vehicle in the sighting or
standing by there it's Tristan and we're
gonna get across to Tristan now he's got
ten Ghana and we gonna try and fire
follow Tandy in Calamba indeed so we
were on the trail of Tenggara all
afternoon and he eventually joined with
James with Tandy and calibre what an
incredible way to spend an afternoon so
you can see ting Ghana's busy sniffing
around it's tricky at the moment because
Tandy and Columbia are running one
waiting on is going the other way and
there's just kind of you know movement
all over the place at this stage and
what he's basically doing at the moment
is he's just sniffing around trying to
figure out exactly who's who and what is
going on I'm pretty sure he was
confronted with so much estrogen at once
he's probably a little bit confused as
to what's happening but once they've
chuffed and they've smelt he'll be
easily be able to work out who they are
he will know the scent for both of these
leopards very very well so Linda whether
or not he knows it's his daughter as
obviously debatable the essentially yes
and the reason why is because all the
time and she's been alive she leaves a
chemical signature behind which
essentially will basically sting Ghana
will know that signature he's bumped
into her periodically through her life
and so she's kind of got he's gotten
used to that smell and knows that that's
not a threat to him as as a female as
well is not going to be a threat to his
territory later so she's quite fine with
it he knows that scent very very well
and on top of that then you've got you
know the fact that he knows Tandy seem
to I'm gonna just try and reposition
slightly
trying to see where he's going the
problem that you have with lipids like
this is that they often will try and
move around nice just through this gap
so it shouldn't take us too long to get
a view of him we just need to kind of
turn through this area here now hold on
since let me just go straight this way
listen that was him telling everybody
I'm the boss here
he's telling Tenley is telling Columba
and this is my area and that sawing is
to tell that he is the dominant male and
in charge of what's going on here look
at that now to get three lipids in a
single sighting is just ridiculous now
ting ganas looks like he's gonna follow
him behind tiny elemen it sounds like
James is stoic Aranda and she's chuffing
away at Andy so we still Columba here
she has moved away from ting Ghana and
she's now between Tandy and Tenggara
Tandy's moved off to the left hand side
of your picture there and it's almost
like she's trying to placate her parents
and bring them back together
she's looking towards Tandy now she's
calling down
and she was doing that straight towards
Tenggara as well he you've just heard
suing and I know there is a lot of
solder on parts just because there are
many excited viewers tastes
I can't see tündi anywhere yeah Josie
says she sounds like a frog she sounds a
little bit like a frog that's eaten
something she shouldn't have and he's
about to try and whoops it up
either the other two only got remember
here I'm just indicating to Aubrey where
they've gone
let's wait here I want to move just yet
because I can't afford to figure out
exactly what's going on so there's two
lumber back towards a month but isn't it
interesting that she's following her
mama who showed her nothing but
displeasure and aggression with those
growls and salivating and then marking
and scraping and her father showed none
of the same in fact I've never seen her
dad not growl at her when he's been
close by the first time I've seen them
react like that okay I think we should
move on but to see if we can catch up
absolutely fantastic stuff
we are of course in the West includin
the sabi sands and that is the area most
world-renowned for great leopard
sightings and this one's lie down
they're both there oh well done
okay so Sebastian says that they are
both Degas we can see them both say when
sit a little bit there we go yeah you
can see them both sorry about the trees
and bushes
so that's a mum looking at us this one
is wider scale is move it away
yeah it's very interesting a lot of you
who've been watching for a long time
noticing that Tandy is barely looks
smaller than it has before we all
thought she might well be pregnant but
many of you saying that her belly looks
a bit smaller yeah I have to agree
so that's tündi on the lift and Colombe
on the right the number of you wondering
if he has a dinner around here maybe
she's given birth well that's possible
certainly possible would be round about
the time but we'd expect an hour we
probably wouldn't see necessarily that
she's lactating it it's early it's early
for her to have another cup if she does
have one destined gana he's marking his
territory with a sawing call as the Sun
sets
honey's just moved off to the left
absolutely fascinating right let's go
back to Tim garner with Tristan
well tinnitus phille sitting in where
they originally met and he's looking in
all the trees very hopeful that he's
going to find himself a little meal that
maybe Tandy or two lumber might have had
but I think he's going to be
disappointed I think this was just a
circumstance thing that they all came
together
but he's lit out a few saws once again
and it looks like he might go following
the two girls to go and see what they
get up to and figure out what's going on
but what an incredible sighting to see
three lipids in the same spot is really
something you don't see every day and
we've been absolutely spoiled by the
fact that we had them now I'm gonna try
and see if I can follow him it's gonna
require a little bit of kind of
maneuvering and a bit of work to get
through the thickets on our sofa and
impale myself as we do this lots and
lots of stumps in this area so one needs
to be a little bit careful about the way
that we do it but pretty sure he's gonna
follow the ladies and I wouldn't be
surprised they all end up at a big pan
that's close by for a drink of water in
the afternoon
I think everybody's realized that
they're not a threat to one another
that's why we're not seeing too much
aggression from tungare he's most
certainly kind of relaxed quite a bit
since he first arrived I think when he
first heard all those shouting in
parlors and probably heard the chuffing
of leopards he probably thought to
himself well there might be an intruder
or something like that and so that's why
he's running the way he did and now he's
kind of figured everybody out I think
he's gonna calm down a bit we gotta try
this get around this little thicket and
then we should be able to get one last
view of him as he gets through this
dense area it really isn't easy
negotiating some of these sections
so James is just here in front of me
and ting ganas should be coming out some
way on our right hand side sins you see
him there is there is on the timid lot I
was gonna try and see if I can get us
one last sort of view he's lying down
now on the mound and I think he's happy
to sit there I'm just gonna make sure I
don't like I say decapitate myself or
sins oh as we make our way through this
area's looking as regal as one could
ever imagine look at that isn't that
special well it is always so nice to see
lipids and particularly so many together
right well it can't get any better than
that
but now the things have sort of calmed
down we're going to say a goodbye to all
of you hope that you absolutely enjoyed
that it really is special to see three
leopards together and if you want to
know what carries on tapping remember
you can just google Safari live and
we'll continue to watch them over the
course of the next few hours this
evening but until then until you see you
guys again next time
it's been an absolute pleasure bye for
now
well that was chaotic in many ways in
one of those afternoons it's been a
crazy crazy often and it was bound to
happen that we were gonna get an
interaction between ting garnet Anita
lumber at some point I'd had to kind of
go the way it is and I believe the guys
are telling me the other I mean I only
saw a brief glimpse of Tandy just now as
she walked but the guys are telling me
that she looks like she's very empty and
that's her milk pouches are quite full
so I wonder if maybe she hasn't given
birth some way around here
it will be very very intriguing if she
has breasts in ghana he's gonna go and
follow where Tandy and Columba are they
obviously on the other side and think
Arn is gonna head off towards where sort
of James is at the moment and we'll have
to try and kind of figure a way to just
stand back and the reason why we kind of
stand quite close is because obviously
if they split apart we want to be able
to follow each one of them and so you
know we'll live there the vehicles view
them and then we'll kind of just
separate and try and figure out what's
going on but in the meantime while I sit
sure and see what happens
taganas going straight towards James's
vehicle at the moment so let's send you
across team we can see that her Luke
pouches do look for
Tunney there looks to me very empty and
it's difficult to tell if she is
lactating or not from here
she's just smelling with Columbus beat
yeah look right next to us yeah we've
got in Ghana and Columba that's it in
Ghana this Columba she's still chopping
away free lipids within three meters of
this she's got baby caps he's not
interested in causing
two straight in front of us she says
chuffing away George George of John
Stanton growling
frog hunting go over to the left there
we go
he's been interested of course you know
what's going on here but as the father
of the new Cubs
I don't think he'd pose them any threat
but any mother leopard with any other
predator including related predators
near her new Cubs be extremely
threatened and therefore potentially
dangerous
oh she's hissing acting gonna take all
of us just standing beyond her to do
what he does best which is sleep you'll
also be rolling to leave the center Jos
eat a number through the bush in front
of us at war crystal
baby on a car next to us making a noise
believe
many of you saying that the society
tends absolutely it is
he comes to Ghana to smell what Andy's
been and returned with me
just keep your eye on Tandy there I'll
explain what tingle is doing he's almost
marking where she was lying he's
salivating they're scraping his back
legs I just want to keep my eye on dandy
dad
that's why she's I go away let's just
beyond overt undies head to the left
relaxed not doing anything watching this
potential parental fighter going on do
you stop chuffing
[Music]
many of you sang new piece of the most
amazing sounds there are and all three
of them making different sounds aren't
they
ting garner with his swing ton d with
her growling and shall humble with her
hissing and chuffing just gonna call
Tristan and tell him to go round the
other side because I think well we might
just wait and see if that other vehicle
doesn't go away at lights you can see is
not the light of heaven but in fact a
spotlight from one of the other vehicles
just absolute magic is that enough he's
seen enough of his daughter and his
consort checked them out seen that there
okay let's see if he moves off
yeah Nana I'm just I'm just saying that
he's struggling to hear what's going on
because of Aradia
right so that's Tandy ten ganas moved
off Tristan will probably try and follow
up on him and we'll stay with these two
of course if either of them move from
here to get over this rather substantial
amount of log yes many of you feeling
but sorry for Dundee if he does have
Cubs and this must be quite distressing
for her you know what it's very
difficult for a leopard to ask somebody
to go away quietly you know you might if
you had a baby and you wanted your
friends to go home you might say how
would you please you know just kind of
go home I'm trying to be a mother lip
doesn't have that it's kind of got a um
I nearly said a bad word it's kind of
got a response it says you get out of
here or I'll kill you or doesn't say
anything at all so yes obviously there
are signs of distress yeah but Dingaan
has moved off I don't think he poses a
threat at all
she's irritated with telomer because it
feels odd to have one cub with the other
and I wonder if any of you can remember
how quickly she became pregnant when
Tambe who was her offspring before trial
amber was and how old he was when she
was pregnant with Columb and I think I'm
guessing yeah I think he was 15 months
or so so maybe about three months older
then Columba I'm sure many of you will
be able to remember that but I think
that's what the story was
so yes I do think she's showing signs of
distress but I don't actually think
there's a huge danger here all righty
let's go across to the vault where I
think there's probably slightly karma
seen in the Maasai Mara
well indeed James it is a well more
peaceful I suppose but so we've had lots
of movement all of the lionesses
eventually stood up little cubs about
her jump and catch her sibling they all
stood up one by one came to this
ginormous fig treat did a scratch
each one of them investigated the male's
the Cubs could right up close and
personal with the males and the male's
got very grumpy a blonde male he moved
right away and the other blonde male
then got caught by all three cubs and he
eventually he decided he's had enough
playing calls making some phenomenal
sounds
quite amazing seeing the Cubs going to
stop jumping on the males one male as a
secret of a grumpy and moved off but
there was no negative behavior
now the male and became a jungle German
he got a bit annoyed but he didn't show
there's another point there didn't
become aggressive with anything he just
decided children I done took after
children and they stood up and walked to
go stand in the corner with his brother
or his coalition mate anyway they are
off to right in the long grass gone back
to sleep
they're gonna stay here which is on
we go another one it's no idea what's
about to happen
lust a little bit of his impetus there
how incredible to see the juma family
coming together like that so interesting
[Music]
Sam's has been recording some phenomenal
stuff here so don't worry there will be
a highlights package no doubt when it
happens it all happens at the same time
there's still Marvel's Wow Dingaan and
Columba can hang out like that that's
really really does interest me I've been
also seeing these three Cubs jumping on
those two adult males was also quite
something you're risking a lot to going
and messing with a big adult back to the
tree and this tree is fine posted by
each lioness these lionesses scratched
herself onto the tree top see here he
comes
everyone's commenting on how cute they
are they're all very cute
very very cute and thankfully they've
come back towards the road where we
originally found whoopsy they we got up
to go
[Music]
Oh
just pulled about the tree down you're
not a leopard you're a lion we live on
the ground
a wonderful contact call in going on
the thankfully as I said that come back
to the road and we would were in there
as a very bumpy lots of rocks at which
way are they going to move
wind is coming out from directly in
front of us sort of coming from the east
that's a good way to go cuz that
direction we would definitely got a
signal
they don't look that way
very very special seem to be
experiencing everybody I hope you're
enjoying them with us as well it's not
it's been a while since I managed to
spend time with a few lion cubs behaving
as they're doing the walk around past us
each of the lionesses in turn has stood
up in front of us and defecated and
thankfully the wind hasn't blown it in
our direction which has been very very
great but anyway
Neela stay here was just proud of lions
and while we do that let's go back down
and see how the leopard drama unfolds in
German right we've got more
conflagration going on here Dundee is
growling zombies hissing that's tündi
we're looking at and you can see that
from her mangled yeah
the lump is just to the left hand side
behind some bushes
let's just tell you that I think glanced
up towards the vehicle that is in the
sighting there is not the one person on
it looking at the livers they're all
looking at their cell phones one two
three four five six seven people looking
at their phones unbelievable
Kirstin saying maybe they're watching
safari life maybe we've just got a bit
of you
it's probably exactly what's going on
[Music]
just here's not going
well they had you answered live the
growling must said need to detract
another predator in the form of Tenggara
so yes absolutely
what does detract hyenas no very
unlikely because they know that this is
a fight unlikely to be a food won't come
investigate Lions Young Lions had come
and look what's going on here
so the interpretation of what's going on
yeah it's quite difficult because
Colombo is behaving in a slightly
aggressive fashion and I wonder if she
isn't experiencing kind of feeling of
you know I should be sort of territorial
now and maybe this old duck needs to
move away and wash around here and of
course the old duck is thinking to
herself how dare you be in this area and
find yourself somewhere else to live
I think I might be quite wrong here but
we're going to see it's a lumber wedge
in between
she dulu to the west and tündi over here
and I think tündi is going to start
spending more and more time towards the
east that's a guess how could be quite
wrong but it would be pretty much how
the territories were if that was to
happen basically it's the number would
take her in assault territory but really
a bit smaller but quite substantially
smaller
so much racing loving anger viciousness
of course we start our TV show in about
half an hour by which time both of these
cats would have disappeared or gone to
sleep which is unfortunate
same with ting ganas at least Tristan's
ting gonna will probably have crossed
south out of the boundary and we'll look
at a couple of chameleons if we're lucky
a pea spider there some hyenas calling
in the background but not because of
this no long way away the curstyn who's
directing the show this evening says
she's hoping for a scrub hair on TV I
don't think that we should get our hopes
up too high Kirsten
let's just keep them under control
I'll tell you we were lucky today
because there is a lot of bush around
and as you've seen and when that first
meeting took place we just happened by a
blind luck to be in the right place
nobody else had the view that we did
the tire blow is tündi
and the light has now faded completely
all righty
yeah let's go back across to Tristan and
let him update you as to whether or not
Kangana is going to leave well as you
can see ting Arnaz just in front of us
walking straight towards us at the
moment so he's going straight south I'm
gonna have to start and just move back
with him otherwise when I block his road
to block the Dukes road but he is
hitting pretty much straight to the
southern boundary and I'm almost 90%
sure he will not be here for the start
of this TV show pretty sure we're gonna
follow him all the way down to the
boundary I mean he's probably at the
rate he's walking ten minutes from
crossing over I'm just hoping he gets to
twin dams has a drink and flops down and
that's the end of it but it doesn't look
like that's gonna be the case it looks
like he's on a mission now now he's been
spurred on by the fact that he's got two
girls to protect and so he's kind of
just making sure that he patrols his
territory and marks see sorry since one
should not watch the leopard and should
actually watch where we're reversing
been doing this and I was gonna get
ourselves into trouble hopefully like I
say he slows down a little bit but at
this stage it's not looking good ting
garnet just will be around
half an hour's time just trying to give
us some decent amount of space for the
show to close so we're gonna try and do
a good sort of 100 meters and see if we
timed this perfectly for the end of our
afternoon so here we go we're gonna stop
yeah this should be it what are your
concerns you think I've gone ninety
seconds I think we too too close for 90
seconds but let's try it let's see how
we go if we he'll stop at some point and
kind of settle down on the road but it
looks like he's coming straight towards
us are they okay thanks tingey we've
done me a solid day because I think
otherwise he would have come past us too
quickly and we would have not so got
this right that's all but um what an
epic afternoon it's been lipids all over
the place no don't go that way now no
now you're going the wrong way you were
supposed to walk straight at us
the new would have had a really nice
walk by you know this is probably gonna
st. mark and then hopefully turn towards
us here there we go he's gonna come
behind a car and then come in our
direction unfortunately though it is
that time where we do need to say
goodbye to all of you and I'm sorry that
you were not giving you a nice frame
here because the car is way too close
where he's rubbing his face in done at
the moment so I do apologize about that
seems to me
but it has been an epic afternoon
hopefully you've all enjoyed it and have
had a good time so from all of us it's
been an absolute pleasure hopefully
we'll see you in half an hour for our TV
show and in tomorrow morning for the
sunrise Safari
[Music]